We're told to look at the
coordinate grid above.
I put it on the side here.
Identify one system
of two lines that
has a single solution.
Then identify one system
of two lines that
does not have a solution.
So let's do the first part
first. So a single solution.
And they say identify one
system, but we can see here
there's actually going to
be two systems that
have a single solution.
And when we talk about a single
solution, we're talking
about a single x and y value
that will satisfy both
equations in the system.
So if we look right here at the
points of intersection,
this point right there, that
satisfies this equation y is
equal to 0.1x plus 1.
And it also satisfies, well,
this blue line, but the graph
that that line represents,
y is equal to 4x plus 10.
So this dot right here, that
point represents a solution to
both of these.
Or I guess another way to think
about it, it represents
an x and y value that satisfy
both of these constraints.
So one system that has one
solution is the system that
has y is equal to 0.1x plus 1,
and then this blue line right
here, which is y is equal
to 4x plus 10.
Now, they only want us to
identify one system of two
lines that has a single
solution.
We've already done that.
But just so you see it, there's
actually another
system here.
So this is one system right
here, or another system would
be the green line and
this red line.
This point of intersection right
here, once again, that
represents an x and y value
that satisfies both the
equation y is equal to 0.1x plus
1, and this point right
here satisfies the equation
y is equal to 4x minus 6.
So if you look at this system,
there's one solution, because
there's one point of
intersection of these two
equations or these two lines,
and this system also has one
solution because it has one
point of intersection.
Now, the second part of the
problem, they say identify one
system of two lines that does
not have a single solution or
does not have a solution,
so no solution.
So in order for there to be no
solution, that means that the
two constraints don't overlap,
that there's no point that is
common to both equations or
there's no pair of x, y values
that's common to
both equations.
And that's the case of the two
parallel lines here, this blue
line and this green line.
Because they never intersect,
there's no coordinate on the
coordinate plane that satisfies
both equations.
So there's no x and y
that satisfy both.
So the second part of the
question, a system that has no
solution is y is equal to 4x
plus 10, and then the other
one is y is equal
to 4x minus 6.
And notice, they have the exact
same slope, and they're
two different lines, they have
different intercepts, so they
never, ever intersect,
and that's why
they have no solutions.